a fortnight ago they had jobs schools
and homes
now they are refugees
three cousins and their four children
in the port yeah
we sit in the floor within hours we
they have family in the uk
but seven long visa forms all in english
took hours every time it's different
information
every two hours
some change change changes in need plus
new documents plus new translators
everything's new
some family helping ukraine and scent
and may and now we make everything seem
translated and
yeah so you've had to have family in
ukraine send you yeah information yeah
his mom is her mother
it is unbelievably difficult with their
husbands in kiev now fighters
they just want somewhere safe to stay we
don't need some
benefit we don't need nothing because we
have his family we need some one two
three three
situation in ukraine is will be good
we're just back
and everyone here has a similar story
things aren't just complicated they are
constantly changing a day ago people
were brought here from calais where they
were told there was a visa center
opening nearby in lille
now they're told it'll open on friday
not here but in harass and that's an
arrow away
some have made it through in the early
hours maria brought her ukrainian mum to
edinburgh people have nowhere to go
some people like run out of money people
like stay
they have no home they just want to make
to their fam like to their family
and the whole process is just is too
long too complicated
after days on the road they're all off
to paris to finish the applications does
it feel welcoming to you the uk
no he's not so welcome now
yeah
but we try we're strong
yeah they've left their hearts in
ukraine but their hope now lies in
britain
laura bunduck sky news in lille